Tuesday April 17th is tax day this year
there'll be publicity about income tax
day but it's misleading because income
taxes are just a fraction of what we pay
and income taxes are arguably way too
high but they actually make up less than
half of our personal tax burden Kristin
Tate just wrote what she calls a field
guide to the American tax ripoff how do
I tax the Explorers the many other taxes
we pay it's crazy
California has a tax on fresh fruit that
comes from vending machines
car registration entertainment tax
admissions tax for movies property taxes
garbage taxes this isn't an exaggeration
every time you do anything you're really
paying taxes rifle tax plane ticket text
but these are tiny taxes well some of
them actually aren't tiny taxes the
reason I wrote this book is because I
was getting charged about $200 a month
by Comcast for my cable bill
thirty-six dollars of it was tax these
kinds of fees are inflating every bill
we pay why should we believe you you're
12 years old oh I did the research all
of this information is available online
the results were shocking what do you
think you pay in taxes most people don't
know what they pay I think it's 22% I'm
probably paying closer to 20% did you
take a plane here I did
did you know you paid 20% in taxes on
your ticket I did not realize it was
that much no how much are you paying for
your hotel it's about $100 a night so
about $20 of that is going right to
taxes
they get us everywhere I think I need to
get a side job to face cash
we need taxes to pay for government of
course we need taxes the problem is that
we're often being taxed without even
knowing it from going to a restaurant
with our friends to buying a movie
ticket to riding the subway we're
getting taxed on those expenses in
Colorado they tax non essential food
items like napkins bibs and straws in
New York they have a bagel cutting tax
which you get charged for whenever you
buy a pre sliced bagel right whole bagel
you don't pay the tip yeah you don't pay
the tax if you buy the whole bagel so I
always get my bagels non sliced to avoid
this tax this is a left-wing town they
love high taxes it's part of the deal if
New Yorkers want to pay high taxes they
can vote for high taxes my problem is
the way that these taxes are implemented
politicians are cowards instead of
creating attacks they magically create
these little fees and they don't have to
tell their voters they raised taxes so
people don't know I have a list here of
100 different taxes that you pay even
big texts want a beer that I drink Uncle
Sam just kills me me you know can you
think of anything you do in life that is
not taxed okay when I sleep am I being
taxed
everything's taxed even when I breathe a
dollar 10 increase in the 911 phone
Tech's 9-1-1 fees pay for important
emergency services actually no in most
states and cities the 911 fees are just
going to general funds Chicago for
instance they hiked their 9-1-1 fee in
2008 there was no Olympics in Chicago
but they kept that fee in place and then
in 2014 they raised it again once they
put them there they almost never go away
absolutely not
government only grows finally there's
the pet licensing tax this is one tax
that Tate and her dog refused to pay in
most cities it doesn't go to dogs it
just goes to the general fund like all
of these
other fees by saying I'm not paying this
you're taking a risk dictate your I am
taking a risk i I just we pay so much of
our money to these dogs put you over the
time it's the little things John the
little things add up what you pay an
income tax is probably less than half
your total tax burden